Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. 34 Spieltage sind in der 2. Bundesliga gespielt. Wir wollen einordnen, die Spiele sortieren und auf die Vereine blicken, gemeinsam mit Christoph Biermann, Buchautor und Reporter bei 11 Freunde. Christoph, guten Morgen. Schön, dass du hier bist.
Ja, guten Morgen.
Ja, was war das für eine Zweitligasaison? Wie fällt dein Fazit aus?
Du meinst irgendwie, wie sportliche Qualität – also ich meine, es war zumindest mal spannend. Also fangen wir mal damit an. Und das muss ich insgesamt sagen. Die 2. Liga hat, sehen wir jetzt mal von der sportlichen Qualität ab, die eben dann doch über weite Strecken, wie der Name schon sagt, zweitklassig ist, ist sie wahnsinnig spannend gewesen. Und das hat natürlich auch damit zu tun, dass, obwohl mit Köln und dem HSV zwei wirtschaftsstarke Giganten darin gewesen sind, insgesamt natürlich die wirtschaftlichen Unterschiede in der 2. Liga nicht so groß sind wie in der Bundesliga. Das heißt, das Feld sortiert sich nicht automatisch schon so stark vor durch das Geld und dadurch gibt es in der 2. Liga einfach weiterhin viel mehr Überraschungen. Und das ist gut. Das macht dann natürlich auch mehr Spaß.
Es ist ja auch logisch, wenn nicht nur die schlechtesten Mannschaften eines Jahres nach unten hin durchgereicht werden, sondern auch die besten nach oben hin plus noch die besten Spieler der Liga regelmäßig in die 1. Liga weg sind, dann muss ja alles ein bisschen zusammenrücken. Aber ist denn die sportliche Qualität wirklich so zweitgleistig in diesem Jahr gewesen?
Ich meine, wir werden es ja am Donnerstag in Stuttgart und am Montag dann an der alten Försterei in Berlin überprüfen können, also wenn dann der Drittletzte auf den Dritten der 2. Liga trifft. Mein Gefühl ist oder mein Eindruck ist, dass der Abstand zwischen der Bundesliga und der 2. Liga über die Jahre deutlich größer geworden ist. Also das würde man jetzt vielleicht nicht denken, wenn man sich die verheerende Saison anguckt, die der Hannover 96 und der 1. FC Nürnberg punktemäßig absolviert haben. Aber insgesamt ist die Lücke riesengroß und dabei sind wir natürlich sehr schnell wieder beim Geld, weil auch der Sprung von der 2. in die 1. Liga auch wirtschaftlich ein sehr großer Unterschied ist. Sicherlich nicht für den 1.
Das stimmt allerdings. Ein Sonderfall ist aber auch der SC Paderborn, der es geschafft hat, direkt aufzusteigen, trotz einer 1 zu 3 Niederlage in Dresden. Paderborn die Fahrstuhlmannschaft auf Speed, die es nie in einer Liga aushält, sondern immer direkt nach oben oder nach unten entwischen muss. Wie hast du diese Partie erlebt und wie würdest du jetzt die Saison von Paderborn einordnen? Wie kann man das erfassen, dass die schon wieder durchmaschieren?
Werden sie wahrscheinlich nächstes Jahr auch wieder, aber gut. Ich fand, dass Paderborn die Mannschaft gewesen ist in der 2. Liga, die den furiosesten Fußball gespielt hat. Sie hat ja auch oft Harakiri gespielt. Das ist jetzt eine Mannschaft, die unheimlich viele Tore geschlossen hat, nämlich 76, aber auch 50 kassiert hat. Das ist ja doch eine ganze Menge für jemanden, der aufsteigen will oder aufsteigt. Das hat schon Spaß gemacht, die anzugucken. Also das hatte immer irgendwie was Wildes und es hatte aber auch was Klares. Also das ist ja kein – was die da gespielt haben ist ja nicht sonderlich geheimnisvoll 4-4-2 relativ konventionell, aber mit klaren Vorgaben und mit Spielern, die sie sehr, sehr gut identifiziert haben, dass die in ihr System reinpassen. Denn das sind ja keine gefallenen Superstars oder so was drin, sondern Jungs, die irgendwo herkommen. Also wir haben zum Beispiel zu Beginn der Rückrunde noch einen Spieler von Rot-Weiß Essen geholt und Rot-Weiß Essen krepelt ja im Mittelfeld der vierten Liga herum. Pröger heißt der und der hat dann mehr oder weniger aus dem Stand es geschafft, da einen Stammplatz zu bekommen bei Paderborn und dieser Mann hat – ich weiß es nicht – 25.000 Euro Ablösesumme gekostet, vielleicht waren es auch 35. Also das ist so die Art und Weise, wie Paderborn das macht, wie Markus Grösche, der Sportdirektor, das er da gemacht hat, eben zusammen mit einem Trainer und das muss ich schon sagen, das fand ich wirklich beeindruckend. Das hat auch, ich meine die meisten Menschen, fünf Kilometer hinter der Stadtgrenze von Paderborn, interessieren sich ja nur wirklich nicht für den FC Paderborn, aber das konnte man sich wirklich gut anschauen.
50 Tore aus dem offenen Spiel herausgemacht, das ist Liga-Bestwert, der erste FC Köln, der insgesamt mehr Tore erzielt hat, nämlich 84, hat da nur 49 erzielt, aber eben auch 50 kassiert in Summe. Das ist so ein bisschen das Spiel des SC gewesen. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das dann in der ersten Liga verfängt. Du hast ja da schon eine kleine Prognose abgegeben, aber jetzt wollen wir den Paderbornern auch nicht die Laune verdaben an der Stelle.
Nö, also die nehmen es ja jetzt, also die wissen ja auch alle, wo sie herkommen, also dass sie vor ziemlich genau zwei Jahren eigentlich in die vierte Liga abgestiegen sind. Wir kennen ja alle die Geschichte. Dann wurde München 60 die Lizenz entzogen. Die durften plötzlich doch wieder dritte Liga spielen und jetzt, 24 Monate später, sind sie in der Bundesliga. Das ist ja so ein bisschen märchenhaft. Sie werden so eine Art von deutschem Huddersfield werden in der kommenden Saison in der Bundesliga. Ich bin auch mal gespannt, ob sie da auch munter auf alles losstürmen, was da entgegenkommt.
Die Handlungsschnelligkeit ist ja einfach der größte Unterschied zwischen 2. und 1. Liga. Verteidigen und angreifen, das können beide vor allem verteidigen können. Eigentlich alle deutschen Mannschaften in den ersten beiden Ligen, würde ich sagen. Aber du hast viel weniger Zeit für deine Entscheidungsfindung in der 1. Liga. Da bin ich gespannt, wie die Spieler das adaptieren.
Ja, es gibt auch noch einen Unterschied. Die Spieler machen natürlich einfach weniger Fehler in der Bundesliga. Also du kannst in der 2. Liga immer das quasi mit einplanen, dass dein Gegner irgendeinen Unforced Error macht, weil er irgendwie halt gerade nicht konzentriert ist oder von der Situation überfordert usw. Und diese Situation, die gibt es in der Bundesliga natürlich viel seltener.
Ja, stimmt, noch ein entscheidender Aspekt. Und dann hatten wir ja auch noch einen Gegner, der Name Dresden hat sich jetzt mit einem Sieg aus der Saison verabschiedet, in der man eigentlich nie so wirklich in Gefahr war. Das sieht man natürlich als Dresdner Anhänger ein bisschen anders, wenn man da emotional drin hängt, ist immer die Gefahr, unten noch mal rein zu rutschen. Aber in Summe war das eine souveräne Saison von Dresden, oder würdest du das wegen der Trainerwechsel dann etwas kritischer sehen?
Also souverän, Dynamo Dresden war dafür, dass es ja ein gigantischer Verein ist. Also das muss man sich ja auch mal klar machen. Also es gibt immer dieses Gerede vom schlafenden Riesen. Also ein schlafender Riese ist Dynamo Dresden sicherlich, weil natürlich historisch so viele Menschen Dynamo Dresden-Fans sind, die leben dann vielleicht gar nicht mehr in Dresden oder in Sachsen, weil sie im Zuge der großen Ost- nach Westmigration längst woanders gelandet sind. Aber natürlich irgendwie diese Anhängigkeit an diesem Club noch haben. Die haben fantastische Zuschauerzahlen. Aber sportlich war das natürlich ja alles in allem farblos. Mit Christian Pfehl haben sie ja eine Legende zum Trainer gemacht im Laufe der Saison. Dann wurde es auch ein bisschen besser. Aber eigentlich ist es natürlich ein gutes Stück unter dem, wo Dynamo Dresden meiner Meinung nach hingehört. Und das ist eigentlich in die Bundesliga.
Aber ist das nicht vielleicht auch genau die Bürde, unter der dann ein solcher Verein wie Dresden – und da könnte man ja auch noch ein paar andere nennen – dann ächzt, dass eben die Erwartungshaltung nicht nur das direkten Umfeld, das ist vielleicht noch realistischer, sondern das erweiterten Umfeld, wo ich dann uns beide mit dazuzählen würde, dass die eben einfach so überhöht ist und Dynamo Dresden in eine Kategorie einordnet, in der man ja sportlich einfach jetzt schon ganz lange nicht mehr dabei war.
Ja, also ich meine, du sagst das ja richtig. Also die Liste dieser Clubs, die sich gefühlt der Bundesliga zugehörig fühlen, die ist ja riesenlang und geht im Zweifelsfalle auch über die 2. Liga hinaus Richtung Kaiserslautern und München 60 und wen wir da sonst noch alles so haben und vielleicht am Ende sogar noch Rot-Weiß essen. Also ja klar, also Erwartungshaltung, die sind vor allen Dingen, wenn man sie dann nicht erfüllt oder erfüllen kann, denn wirtschaftlich ist natürlich Dynamo Dresden jetzt nicht aus dem standen Kandidat, um in die Bundesliga aufzusteigen, da ist das Loch noch viel zu groß. Also diese Erwartungen, die können einem natürlich ganz schön bleischwer in den Kleidern hängen.
Gut, am Ende war es jetzt mit 42 Punkten 7 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz, den Ingolstadt belegt hat. Wenn wir bei Erwartungsmanagement sind, dann können wir auch ganz galant überleiten, zu Union Berlin, die in Bochum angetreten sind und sich jetzt mit dem Relegationsplatz begnügen müssen. Noch nicht wissen, ob sie für die 1. Liga planen können oder weiter das Zweitliga-Ugestein bleiben. Keine Mannschaft in der aktuellen Liga ist länger in der 2. Liga mit dabei, nämlich seit 2009, 2010 der 1. FC Union. Du hast das Spiel gegen Bochum vermutlich sehr genau verfolgt, weil dir der VfL am Herzen liegt. Wie ist denn da Union aufgetreten?
Sehr enttäuschend. Sie haben ja am Ende 2 zu 2 gespielt und hatten dann sogar noch kurz verschluss eine große Chance zum 3 zu 2, also das Spiel zu gewinnen und dann in die Bundesliga aufzusteigen. Letztendlich, dass sie überhaupt aufgeholt haben, hatte was damit zu tun, dass sie dann irgendwann in Überzahl spielten, weil eine wie ich fand, ja, etwas harte, gelb-rote Karte für den Bochumer Stürmer Gangula vergeben wurde. Aber bis dahin, also bis in diese letzten 10 Minuten hinein, wirkte das Ganze unheimlich gehemmt und ein bisschen blockiert. Man muss allerdings, ehrlicherweise auch sagen, dass Union Berlin – es ist keine spielstarke Mannschaft. Also das ist eine Mannschaft, die unheimlich geordnet ist, die also normalerweise auch wenig Gegentore kassiert. Also dass sie da 2 zu 0 in Bochum zurücklag, war eher ungewöhnlich. Das ist eine Mannschaft, die viel über Standardsituationen, lange Bälle und so weiter kommt. Und das verfing in Bochum überhaupt nicht und wirkte ein bisschen einfallslos. Und mir fehlt ehrlich gesagt sehr die Fantasie, wie sich diese Mannschaft in der Relegation gegen Stuttgart durchsetzen sollte.
Ja, das ist mir auch aufgefallen. Dieses Festhalten an langen Bällen. Und von den blanken Zahlen her hatte Union Berlin natürlich vor allem dann nach dem Platzverweis die klare Spieldominanz. 26 zu 8 Abschlüsse, 8 zu 2 Torschüsse. Also die beiden Torschüsse von Bochum waren dann tatsächlich auch im Tor. Aber insgesamt war das sehr auf Zufall aufgelegt. Auf zweite Bälle, die man bekommt. Da kann man den Zufall minimieren, aber nicht komplett rausnehmen. Es hatte auch manchmal ein bisschen hektische Züge, fand ich. Und vor allem in der Schlussphase, als man dann in der 83. und 86. Minute nochmal erziehen konnte, da finde ich, hat man deutlich gesehen, dass Union da der Spieler gefehlt hat, der das vielleicht auch in Ruhe, den Vortrag nach vorne gespielt hätte. Auch wenn das natürlich sich leicht sagt, jetzt hier aus der Distanz und es geht um den Aufstieg und ist in der Nachspielzeit. Aber man hatte doch diese fünf Minuten Nachspielzeit, da musste noch mehr als diese eine Chance heraus spielen können. Und da hat sich Union Berlin durch dämliche Fouls, durch einmal noch einen Abstoß irgendwie, den man vielleicht noch hätte verhindern können, dann auch noch Freistoß für den VfL an der Strafraumkante von Union selber so ein bisschen ins Hintertreffen gebracht. Und das fand ich mit Blick eben darauf, dass jetzt noch zwei Spiele kommen, in denen genau das gefragt sein wird, nämlich, dass du so gut es geht noch einen kühlen Kopf bewahrst und an einem Plan festhältst, auch in einer stressigen Situation. Fand ich das mit Blick auf die Relegation auch nicht allzu vielversprechend aus Unioner Sicht.
Ja, kann ich sozusagen nur ein Häkchen hinter machen. Das war auch mein Eindruck.
Jetzt haben wir ja mit dem Gegner dann diejenige Mannschaft, die nach Union Berlin am längsten in der zweiten Liga ist. Dein VfL Bochum seit 2010, 2011. Was für eine Saison war das für den VfL? Sie wird jetzt beendet auf dem elften Platz mit 44 Punkten. Wie würdest du das einordnen?
Ja, das war eine sehr seltsame Saison. Ich stelle mal in Klammern was voran, was für diese Geschichte nicht unwichtig ist. Auch in Bochum gibt es eigentlich die Erwartung, dass man eigentlich Bundesligist ist. Die Realität ist natürlich eine ganz andere. Der VfL Bochum hat einen Etat, der so mittlere 2. Liga garantiert. Also so Clubs wie Union Berlin oder St. Pauli zum Beispiel, um jetzt gar nicht über Köln und Hamburg zu sprechen, sind da eine ganze Ecke weit weg. Und trotzdem haben alle das Gefühl, dass man aufsteigen müsste. Und es ist ein bisschen auch das Problem, meiner Meinung nach, dass dieser Club in den letzten Jahren zu häufig dieses auch als Ziel propagiert hat, obwohl es meiner Meinung nach mehr oder weniger unrealistisch gewesen ist. Also klar, das Beispiel von Paderborn oder in der Vergangenheit von Fürth oder sowas zeigt, dass man auch mit kleineren Ressourcen durchkommen kann, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist halt geringer. Und dann war es interessant in dieser Saison, dass der VfL ja als Fürther in die Winterpause gegangen ist, auch nach einem allerdings sehr, sehr glücklichen 3 zu 2-Sieg beim 1. FC Köln und dann in der Rückrunde quasi eingebrochen ist. Also das hatte auch damit zu tun, dass es eine quasi epidemische Flut von Verletzungen gegeben hat, wo eigentlich fast kontinuierlich 9, 10, 11 Spieler gefehlt haben. Ich war jetzt auch nicht überrascht, dass am Ende der Saison dann zum Beispiel auch der Fitnesstrainer nicht weiter beschäftigt wurde. Denn wenn man so viel Verletzungen hat, hat das sicherlich auch was mit der Trainingssteuerung zu tun. Und es war auch noch das Problem, dass sich angedeutet hat, dass es natürlich eine Mannschaft ist, die am Ende der Reise angekommen war, also altersmäßig, also mit einer Fülle von Spielern, die eben eine Drei davor hatten oder sehr in der Nähe davon gewesen sind. Und so wird es jetzt nach dieser Saison einen sehr großen Umbruch gehen. Also schon jetzt ist klar, dass mindestens neun Spieler den Verein verlassen werden. Das heißt, es werden auch eine Menge neue kommen. Und dann muss halt der Sissi Voss den Ball, die Kugel, da wieder den Berg erneut draufrollen. Ich bin interessant, vielleicht finde das der eine oder andere komisch, gar nicht so unzufrieden gewesen. Ich finde, dass alles in allem oft ordentlicher Fußball gespielt worden ist. Also Bochum hat sicherlich zu den kombinations- und spielstärkeren Mannschaften der Liga gehört, aber wie gesagt, in der Rückrunde ist das komplett abgerissen.
Und wie würdest du jetzt den größeren Kontext vom VfL einordnen? Also wir haben eben auf der einen Seite eine Mannschaft, die Erstligageschichte hat, da können sich auch viele dran erinnern und dementsprechend auch diesen Anspruch. Auf der anderen Seite hast du ja aber auf die wirtschaftlichen Rahmenbedingungen auch schon drauf eingegangen. Ich stelle mir immer die Frage, so bitter es ist, aber würde denn einer Mannschaft wie dem VfL einen Aufstieg überhaupt helfen? Denn die genannten Gegenbeispiele, die du hattest, mit Greuther Fürth zum Beispiel, da hat man ja genau das erlebt. Klar, man kann dann schon mal aufsteigen, um das jetzt mal so salopp zu formulieren. Und dann hast du ein Erstligajahr, dass du dann eher unter Aktivitäten am Wochenende abstempeln kannst. Sportlich ist das nicht immer dann so erfreulich. Und dann gehst du direkt wieder runter. Du hast zwar einmalig höhere Einnahmen durch die TV-Gelder, allerdings mit Prämien-Auszahlungen und so weiter, glaube ich, nivelliert sich das dann auch relativ schnell. Ist das nicht vielleicht einfach so, dass der VfL inzwischen eine Zweitligamannschaft ist und wirtschaftlich da steht, wo er hingehört, und das dann vielleicht auch so schwer es ist, dem Umfeld peu à peu vermitteln müsste?
Also der VfL hat ja als Ziel ausgegeben, als quasi ein bisschen neue Zielrichtung Top 25. Also das ist jetzt mit dem elften Platz natürlich deutlich verfehlt. Das halte ich aber für realistisch, also zu sagen, ja vielleicht steigt man mal ein Jahr auf und frisst sich da ein bisschen Speck an und ein bisschen auch, weiß ich nicht, man bekommt wieder ein bisschen größere Aufmerksamkeit. Es ist ganz interessant, ich habe den Eindruck, dass der VfL bei vielen neutralen Fußballfans, oder was heißt neutralen Fußballfans, bei vielen Fußballfans ein Verein ist, der durchaus sympathisch betrachtet wird. Also was auch damit zu tun hat, dass das Ruhrstadion und das meine ich, das ist sicherlich nicht nur Vereinsbrille eines der tollsten Stadien in Deutschland ist, weil es wirklich auf angenehme Art und Weise oldschool ist. Man kann von überall wunderbar gucken, es ist nicht so groß, es ist nicht so anonym und so weiter und so weiter. Menschen von anderen Clubs fahren da gerne hin, weil es auch mitten in der Stadt liegt und und und. Aber es braucht schon mal wieder ein bisschen mehr Erfolge und da würde selbst so ein Jahr, ich lege jetzt mal eine Formulierung von Dirk Zingler, dem Präsidenten von Union Berlin aus, so ein Jahr Urlaub in der Bundesliga, das wird da sehr helfen.
Ja, ist dann ja auch so ein bisschen eine emotionale Frischzellenkur, würde ich es dann mal nennen. Also der VfL, jetzt dann sollte Union Berlin aussteigen, wäre es die Mannschaft mit der längsten Zweitliga-Zugehörigkeit in der nächsten Saison beendet. Diese jetzt auf Tabellenplatz 11 mit 44 Punkten. Das waren die Entscheidungen oben, dass wir Paderborn als Direktaufsteiger sehen und Union Berlin als Relegationsteilnehmer. Dann gab es auch noch Entscheidungen unten zu treffen und da hat es zum einen der SV Sandhausen aus eigener Kraft geschafft, mit einem 2 zu 2 bei Regensburg den Abstieg bzw. die Relegation zu vermeiden. Sandhausen immer so ein bisschen das Sim-Bild des Spottes über die 2. Liga. Dann muss man ja nach Sandhausen, ist so ein bisschen das geflügelte Wort, wenn wir uns jetzt mal von diesem Zerrbild lösen wollen. Was ist denn das für eine Mannschaft gewesen in dieser Saison und wie ordnest du das ein, dass man es jetzt eben geschafft hat, mit Tabellenplatz 15 in der Liga zu bleiben?
Also ich muss gestehen, ich war noch nie in Sandhausen. Vielleicht muss ich da einfach mal hinfahren. Obwohl natürlich, muss man ja jetzt mal ehrlich sein, also das, was Sandhausen ist, beachtlich. Also staunenswert, diese Ausdauer. Wievielte Jahre sind die jetzt am Stück drin?
Sandhausen ist der viert längste Zweitliga-Teilnehmer, also seit 2012, 2013.
Und das ist natürlich schon sehr beachtlich, weil, aber es ist natürlich auch, wie soll ich das sagen, Sandhausen hat es geschafft, ich will es mal positiv formulieren, Sandhausen hat es geschafft, über all die Jahre eine unglaubliche Zähigkeit an den Tag zu legen und es allen Gegnern schwer zu machen, wenn man dahingefahren ist, wenn man gegen die gespielt hat. Und das ist Uwe Koschin hat jetzt auch wieder gelungen. Und dafür muss man natürlich großen Respekt haben, weil diese Mannschaft hat ja wenig, was sie von außen trägt. Ja, also wenn man jetzt irgendwie für Union Berlin spielt oder irgendwie sowas. Also da wird man schon mal von dem drum herum mitgenommen. Sowas gibt es ja bei Sandhausen in dem Sinne nicht. Und von daher, also mein Respekt hat das. Aber wie gesagt, es ist halt auch zäh mit unseren Freunden aus Sandhausen.
Ja, es ist ein Zweitligastandort, der sportlich jetzt genügend häufig nachgewiesen hat, das er Zweitliga-Format hat. Aber alles andere scheint eben einfach immer noch zu klein zu sein. Also allein, wenn du dir den Zuschauerschnitt anguckst, das war in dieser Saison, liegt der bei 6.900 Zuschauern. Also knapp die 7.000 Zuschauer. Das ist der schlechteste Zweitliga.
Und da muss man ja immer denken, wie viele Leute sind da aus Hamburg hingefahren, wie viele Leute sind da aus Köln hingefahren und so weiter und so. Weiter. Ja, das heißt, für sich gesehen haben sie wahrscheinlich einen Schnitt von, also so ein Kern von zweieinhalb, dreitausend Zuschauern. Das ist natürlich schon, aber gut. Also mein Respekt haben sie trotzdem und das sage ich jetzt nicht nur so dahin, weil da sind in der Zeit etliche, viel, viel größere mit viel, viel besseren Möglichkeiten abgestiegen.
Und ziehst du deinen Hut dann auch vor der Leistung von Jan Regensburg, die jetzt auf Tabellenplatz acht einlaufen mit 49 Punkten. Und wir wissen ja, der Trainer, der bei diesem 2 zu 2 auf der Trainerbank saß, Achim Bayer-Lorz, wird in der nächsten Saison erstklassig trainieren dürfen und spielen dürfen beim 1. FC Köln.
Dass das so kommt, hat mich ehrlich gesagt nicht überrascht, weil die haben das ja in der letzten Saison schon sehr, sehr ordentlich gemacht. Das ist halt klasse, klarer RB-Fußball, der den Bayer-Lorz zerspielen lässt. Und das ist oft hochenergetisch natürlich, wenn man so einen Fußball mit schlechteren Spielern als in Leipzig spielen lässt, ist das natürlich auch manchmal ein hektisches Rumgepicke, der allerersten Güte. Aber gut, die haben das klasse gemacht, haben ein paar gute Spieler dabei. Und ja, also wie gesagt, mich hat es nicht überrascht. Ich habe mich mal versucht zu erinnern, wie ich vor der Saison getippt habe, wer wo reinläuft. Ich werde auch gleich meine größte Miss-Tipp outen. Aber Jan Regensburg, die hatte ich da irgendwo hingetippt. Und übrigens Paderborn hatte ich, glaube ich, auch ins erste Drittel getippt, zumindestens. Aber wie gesagt, da gibt es noch andere Personen, die ich noch andere freundlich finde.
Das wäre ja auch komisch, wenn nicht. Ansonsten machen wir ein Sportwetten-Podcast das nächste Mal. Aber sag mir mal, ist das nicht erstaunlich, dass man mit einem Fußball, der eben nach diesen Rasenball-Sportprinzipien, würde ich sie jetzt nennen, funktioniert, dass den immer noch so wenige Mannschaften kopieren, dass es dann in Anführungszeichen reicht, dass man diesen Spielstil dann zu einem anderen Verein trägt und sich dann damit so deutlich von allen anderen abhebt, dass man in der Regel dann auch die entsprechenden Resultate einfängt. Warum kommt sich das nicht mehr?
Wir werden in der nächsten Saison also sechs Trainer haben, die direkt oder indirekt, also in der Bundesliga, Bundesliga 1 von diesem RB-Fußball inspiriert sind. Also neben Bayer-Lorz, jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, haben wir natürlich noch Marco Rose, das ist dann eine bisschen andere Version, Adi Hütter, auch eine bisschen andere Version, der hat es ja auch in Salzburg nicht lange ausgehalten. Dann Paderborn, das hat auch durchaus solche Elemente. Ich habe sie mir noch alle aufnotiert, wen habe ich jetzt vergessen, also es waren jedenfalls sechs, die direkt oder indirekt von diesem Fußball inspiriert sind. Und da merkt man schon, dass da eine Denkschule Platz hat und ich meine, das sind Leute, die mit Rangnick, auch David Wagner ist natürlich noch jemand, der sich explizit auf Rangnick bezieht und Helmut Groß, sein großer Denker im Hintergrund, also ich finde, das ist schon massiv, also kann man nicht anders sagen.
Stimmt, da hast du meine Perspektive, mein Argument komplett ausgehöhlt und ich werde jetzt in Zukunft genau in die gegengerechte Richtung argumentieren, das war doch schon mal sehr gewinnbringend auf jeden Fall für mich. Lass uns dann auf die Mannschaft gucken, die in die Relegation gegen den Abstieg muss, nämlich den FC Ingolstadt, trotz eines bemerkenswerten Synosson-Finales, gingen jetzt hinten raus die Luft aus und man hat mit 2 zu 4 in Heidenheim verloren. Es wäre auch mit dem Sieg vermutlich eng geworden, aufgrund der schlechteren Tordifferenz im Vergleich zu Sandhausen. Aber das war ja vielleicht die bemerkenswerteste Entwicklung der letzten Wochen in der 2. Liga, dieser Lauf, in den sich Ingolstadt reingespielt hat.
Und jetzt sind wir genau bei dem, wo ich am weitesten daneben gelegen habe. Ich habe nämlich Ingolstadt auch in die Relegation getippt, allerdings in die zur Bundesliga vor dieser Saison. Also das ist natürlich eine Mannschaft, die ja eigentlich wirklich gut besetzt ist, in der eine Menge interessanter, guter Spieler – Lescano, Kittel oder sowas – also sind Spieler, die, würde mich nicht wundern, dann am Ende der Saison dann doch mal in der Bundesliga landen. Also offensichtlich hat Thomas Oral, den ja immer so etwas, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf, irre Flackern umgibt. Es geschafft dann diese Ingolstädter, die in irgendwelchen, glaube ich, gröberen, internen Wirrnissen verfangen waren, dann doch noch irgendwie hinzubekommen, wahrscheinlich mit viel dunkelflackernden Dingen. Ich bin mal gespannt. Ich kann mir auch da jetzt, ich kenne jetzt die Spielqualität von Wien, Wiesbaden, ich habe da null Ahnung, aber Ingolstadt ist natürlich eigentlich von der Besetzung her eine Mannschaft, die da unten eigentlich gar nichts mit zu tun hat. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn sie diese Relegation überstehen und so an so ein paar Stellschrauben drehen, dass sie auch nächste Saison raketenartig wieder viele, viele Plätze nach vorne kommen. Aber wie gesagt, da müssen sie erstmal über die Runden kommen.
Das gucken wir uns dann einfach an, wie die Relegation verläuft. Damit haben wir den Relegationsteilnehmer. Dann gab es an diesem 34. Spieltag noch die Konstellation, dass die beiden Absteiger jeweils bei Mannschaften antreten durften oder mussten gegen Mannschaften spielen durften, die eigentlich mit dem Ausstieg zu tun haben wollten. Die eine Mannschaft hat es geschafft, der 1. FC Köln, die haben in Magdeburg mit 1 zu 1 gespielt. Die andere Mannschaft, der Hamburger SV, hat sich mit einem 3 zu 0 versöhnlich aus dieser Zweitligasaison verabschiedet von den eigenen Fans im Wissen. Nächstes Jahr wird man noch ein Jahr in der 2. Liga spielen, bevor wir über Köln und den HSV sprechen. Lass kurz dann mal auf Magdeburg und Duisburg blicken, um dieses Abstiegssegment ein bisschen dicht zu machen. Am Ende ist es nie überraschend, wenn ein Aufsteiger wie Magdeburg dann direkt wieder herunter muss in die 3. Liga. Dort wurde das Erwartungsmanagement, weil wir das vorhin als Thema hatten, auch schon dementsprechend betrieben, dass wir gesagt hatten, das könnte jetzt schon ein Abschied für länger sein. Wir werden das Wort Wiederaufstieg nicht direkt in den Mund nehmen. Woran ist denn der 1. FC Magdeburg gescheitert, deiner Analyse nach?
Es ist ganz einfach, die Spieler waren nicht gut genug. Also ich fand, dass Magdeburg die Saison über insgesamt immer den Eindruck gemacht hat, dass sich da alle wahnsinnig Mühe geben, dass sich da alle durchgehend reinhängen und dass dann nichts, ach, weiß ich nicht, also so Abstiegskampf typisch zerbröselt oder sowas. Dann haben sie ja zur Rückrunde dann oder kurz vor Beginn der Rückrunde haben sie ja dann nochmal den Trainer gewechselt, also Aufschießtrainer Jens Hertel, Michael Öning. Michael Öning hat dann ja auch deutlich mehr Punkte geholt, auch mit anderem Personal. Sie haben ja die Mannschaft nochmal ein bisschen verbessert. Hatten dann aber auch noch ein paar Verletzungsprobleme. Also dieser Mannschaft hat es weder an Herz gefehlt, noch an Unterstützung, noch an Zusammenhalt mit dem Publikum. Ich finde auch, dass beide Trainer auf ihre Art und Weise das sehr, sehr ordentlich gemacht haben. Aber wenn man sich das angeguckt hat, sie haben kaum Torschancen herausgespielt. Sie haben einen wirklich halbwegs torgefährlichen Spieler gehabt. Das ist natürlich dann das Problem, wenn man so viele Jahre wie Magdeburg in den unteren Spielklassen rumhängt, dann hat man auch keine große Wirtschaftskraft, trotz dieser tollen zuschauerischen Netz und dieser sagenhaften Unterstützung, um qualitativ etwas bessere Spieler zu holen. Das wäre natürlich schon ganz schön, wenn die wieder aufsteigen würden, weil das ist ja beeindruckend gewesen, wie diese Mannschaft vom Publikum unterstützt worden ist.
Mit einigen Ausreißern, aber da wollen wir jetzt mal nicht die Minderheit über die Mehrheit siegen lassen.
Ja, klar. Wo man vielleicht in Magdeburg auch mal drüber nachdenken könnte, ist, dass man den Aufenthalt für Leute, die von auswärts kommen, ein bisschen freundlicher macht und nicht so häufig dann auch Feindseligkeit inszeniert. Aber das ist, wie gesagt, eine andere Geschichte.
Eine andere Geschichte war ja dann auch der Abstieg des MSV Duisburg. Der war sehr deutlich sieben Punkte Rückstand, sind es jetzt am Ende auf den Relegationsplatz gewesen. Zwischendurch hat man da auch den Trainer gewechselt. Torsten Lieberknecht kam am Anfang, am 1. Oktober hat er übernommen beim MSV. Was hat da gefehlt, jetzt auch vielleicht in Vergleich zum anderen Absteiger Magdeburg?
Also bevor ich jetzt was über den Trainer sage, würde ich vielleicht eher was über den Manager Ivo Grilic sagen, der ja schon ewig da ist und der in den letzten Jahren – also der MSV hatte ja in der Vorsaison eine wirklich gute, sehr erfolgreiche Saison – eine katastrophale Transferbilanz hatte. Also ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendein Spieler, der im vergangenen Sommer gekommen ist, dass man den mal nur annähernd als erfolgreichen Neueinkauf sehen konnte. Also sie hatten irgendwie zwischendurch glaube ich vier Mittelstürmer oder sowas und einer schlechter als der andere. Also für mich immer ein, weil ich den in Bochum halt auch gesehen habe, also wo es mich immer schaudert ist, wenn ich Richard Sokuta-Pasu spielen sehe. Aber der ist jetzt in China glaube ich. Aber anyhow, also das ist wirklich ähnlich wie Magdeburg, aber eben mit einer ganz anderen Vorgeschichte, die Spieler einfach eindeutig zu schlecht. Und Thorsten Dieberknecht hat jetzt, der kam, gewann dann das allererste Spiel beim ersten FC Köln. Und dass der da jetzt irgendwie größer die Dinge veredelt hätte, das kann man jetzt auch nicht sagen. Also ich habe, einer meiner besten Freunde ist MSV Duisburg-Fan und von daher habe ich das Leiden an dieser Mannschaft mitbekommen. Also die Duisburger sind die in der zweiten Liga gewesen, die eindeutig am wenigsten Spaß hatten. Also ja, es gibt noch welche, aber auf die kommen wir ja gleich wahrscheinlich noch.
Aber das hört sich ja auch nicht so wahnsinnig optimistisch an, wenn du die Probleme eher eine Ebene überträner und Mannschaft festmachst, wenn wir jetzt dann eben auf Wiederaufstieg und so weiter blicken.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, Grilic ist ja nicht ohne Grund viele Jahre da, weil er es halt auch echt oft gut gemacht hat. Das Problem des MSV Duisburg ist natürlich, dass sie immer auf sehr dünnem Eis unterwegs sind und jetzt steigen sie in die dritte Liga ab und alle raufen sich die Haare, ob das irgendwie mit der Lizenz hinhaut und so weiter. Und wie kriegt man das hin? Also es besteht dann auch immer die Gefahr, dann da in dieser dritten Liga hängen zu bleiben bzw. wenn es ganz blöd läuft, auf einmal in der Regionalliga festzustecken.
Ja, und es ist dann eben ein bisschen, ist man an der Qualitätsfrage im Sturm, so wie du es gesagt hast, auch gescheitert. Wenn man sich einfach nur die Schüsse pro Spiel anguckt, dann liegt der MSV auf Platz 7. Aber wenn man sich dann die Chancenverwertung anguckt, dann liegt der MSV auf dem drittletzten Platz. Nur Fürth und Magdeburg haben aus ihren weniger herausgespielten Chancen noch weniger Ertrag erzielt. Also das war so mit eines der Hauptprobleme beim MSV. Bei Magdeburg hast du es ja auch schon genannt. Und dann haben wir jetzt die andere Seite der Medaille, jeweils in den Gegnern dieser beiden Teams. Zum einen der Aussteiger der 1. FC Köln hat es jetzt geschafft, aufzusteigen in die 1. Liga, aber verbunden mit einem Trainerwechsel von Markus Anfang hin zu Achim Bayer-Lorzer. Ich habe, ich glaube, vor zwei Wochen hier im Rasenfunk gesagt, dass es der schlechtes Gelauntete-Aufsteiger, an den ich mich erinnern kann. Was ist da passiert beim FC in dieser Saison?
Da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, dass ich das nicht richtig zu beurteilen vermag. Weil, also ich meine, diese Mannschaft ist so grotesk, also wenn wir jetzt eben über Qualität bei Magdeburg und Duisburg gesprochen haben, also da ist wirklich der 1. FC Köln am komplett anderen Ende. Also ein Sturm, der alles in Grund und Boden schießt und am Ende kommt noch Modest dazu. Also das ist so ein bisschen wie, keine Ahnung, du bist jetzt noch, du bist eh schon im Ferrari unterwegs und kriegst dann noch so ein Raketen-Turbo zugeschaltet oder so was. Ich habe das, ich muss da so ein bisschen passen. Ich habe zwar 20 Jahre in Köln gewohnt, aber ich habe, und ich kenne auch so ein bisschen die Stimmung und Stimmung um den 1. FC Köln, aber das ist mir alles ein bisschen ein Mirakel gewesen. Allerdings muss man auch sagen, die haben natürlich auch wahnsinnig viele Gegentore bekommen. Das heißt, Markus Anfang hat es schon auch nicht hinbekommen, eine Balance richtig zwischen dieser überragenden Offensive und einer dann doch irgendwie erstaunlich wackeligen Defensive hinzubekommen. All die internen Konflikte mit Armin Fee und ob die Mannschaft ihn nicht akzeptiert hatte, ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe nicht mit in der Kabine gesessen.
Dann, da über den 1. FC Köln wird noch viel geredet werden, jetzt ja dann auch in der nächsten Erstligasaison. Der angesprochene Sturm auf jeden Fall überragend mit Simon Terode, den Torjäger der Liga gestellt und mit John Cordoba dann auch den 2. platzierten in dieser Tabelle, einmal 29 Tore für Terode, 20 dann für Cordoba, 6 hat er noch modest geschossen in der Zeiten, in der er da war. Das sind beeindruckende Zahlen und die wenige Beeindruckenden sind dann die auf die Defensive bezogen. Aber da gucken wir uns einfach an mit dem Aufstieg in die 1. Liga, verschieben sich ja die Vorzeichen sowieso wieder in so einer Art und Weise, dass man dann vielleicht auch an der Stelle legitimerweise nach vorne guckt und nicht immer nur nach hinten, da wird sich der Anspruch an den 1. FC Köln sowieso verändern. Für den HSV wird er jedoch gleich bleiben, weil man eben in dieser Liga bleiben muss und das eben trotz all der Ambitionen und auch der Strukturen, die man beim HSV vorzuweisen hat. Am Ende fehlt jetzt ein Pünktchen und noch ein paar geschossene Tore. Man kann jetzt beliebige Spiele heraussuchen, die der HSV verloren hat und kann sagen, daran hat es gelegen. Was ist denn aber, wenn man einen Strich drunter macht, deiner Einschätzung nach, der Grund dafür, dass der HSV jetzt Zweitklassik bleibt?
Das ist halt der Zusammenbruch in der Rückrunde. Also der HSV war ja in der Hinrunde. Also auch, wenn das jetzt alles nun wenig aufregend, funkelnd und mitreißend gewesen ist, ist der ja auf Kurs gewesen. Und ich habe mir den letzten Stand der Rückrundetabelle nicht angeguckt, aber der lag ja mal sozusagen sogar auf Abstiegsplatz.
Er hat sich gerettet auf Platz 15. Punktgleich mit dem 16. der Rückrundetabelle Kräuter-Fürth. Also da war das 13. sehr wichtig.
Genau. Und das sagt ja im Grunde genommen alles. Also die Probleme sind eindeutig in der zweiten Saisonhälfte gewesen. Und das erstaunlicherweise – also das ist ja klar, dass der entscheidende Punkt, der war der Wechsel von der ersten Halbzeit des Spiels gegen Darmstadt zur zweiten Halbzeit. Also wir erinnern uns noch mal kurz, der HSV hatte dieses sehr, sehr überspannte, anmoderierte Derby bei St. Pauli mit 4 zu 0 gewonnen, führte im nächsten Spiel gegen Darmstadt 98 zu Hause 2 zu 0, spielte prima, also wirklich so ein bisschen befreit vor sich hin und verlor dieses Spiel 3 zu 2 und danach, wenn ich mich nicht sehr täusche, war der nächste Sieg dann eben der von gestern gegen Duesburg. Und also das ist natürlich, das ist dann auch mit so Dingen wie, was weiß ich, der HSV hat es natürlich eindeutig an Qualität im Mittelfeld, vor allen Dingen an kreativer Qualität im Mittelfeld gefehlt, weil natürlich auch dieser HSV, als die namhaft große Mannschaft dieser Liga oft auf sich tief hinten verbuddelnde Gegner zugekommen ist und so weiter und so fort, da ist ihnen nun wirklich nicht sehr viel eingefallen. Aber auch das ist nicht die Erklärung dafür. Da muss eine Menge schiefgelaufen sein, dieses Zerwürfen mit Louis Holtby zum Schluss der Saison steht ja irgendwie dafür. Man hatte auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass vielleicht der eine oder andere, der wusste, dass er weggeht, AAP oder bei dem so die Reise zu Ende geht, La Soga dann auch nicht mehr so durchgezogen haben, wie man das erwarten würde. Aber es war natürlich über die ganze Saison eine echt zähe Angelegenheit, auch den HSV anzugucken. Ich finde, dass sie mit Douglas Santos zum Beispiel einen Spieler dabei hatten, der quasi grotesk überqualifiziert war für die Anforderungen der 2. Liga, aber daneben dann doch auch eine Menge Kicker. Ich glaube, die HSV-Fans haben auch als gepunktet worden und es nicht sehr viel Spaß gehabt.
Ja, es war eine interessante Saison der HSV mit weitem Abstand. Die Mannschaft mit dem meisten Ballbesitz in der 2. Liga, 57 Prozent. Und das ist auch alles, woran ich mich erinnern kann, wenn ich mich an HSV spiele, die ich gesehen habe in dieser 2. Liga, erinnere, dass der HSV den Ball hatte, meistens im eigenen Aufbau-Drittel. Und dann enden meine Erinnerungen schon sehr bald. Also da ist nicht mehr allzu viel passiert. Wir haben auch noch ein paar Mannschaften, die jetzt am 34. Spieltag einen ganz, ganz entspannten Saison-Ausklang feiern konnten mit ihren Fans. Da gehören zum Beispiel Aminia Bielefeld und Holstein Kiel dazu. Am Ende gewinnt Bielefeld mit 1 zu 0 und schließt sie sogar noch zu Holstein auf. Bielefeld jetzt auf Platz 7 in der Abschlusstabelle und Holstein Kiel auf Platz 6. Was sind das für zwei Mannschaften und was für eine Saison haben sie gespielt?
Eigentlich war das ein bisschen so ein nominelles Spitzenspiel, auch wenn es gestern völlig uninteressant war. Ich fand, dass Holstein Kiel den interessantesten Fußball gespielt hat in der 2. Bei Paderborn haben wir dieses Mitreißende genannt. Bei Köln war es die schiere Macht. Bei Kiel war es einfach guter Fußball, beziehungsweise Fußball, wie ich ihn mag, Kombinationsfußball, Positionsspiel, sich etwas einfallen lassen. Das konnte man sich oft gut angucken. Dass der VfB Stuttgart jetzt dem Walther den Trainer von Kiel verpflichtet hat oder höchst wahrscheinlich verpflichtet wird zur kommenden Saison, das kann man nur verstehen. Er hat das toll gemacht. Das war oft interessant anzugucken. Am Ende ist es ein bisschen auseinander gebröselt, vielleicht natürlich auch, weil da zu viele Leute wussten, dass es für sie den nächsten woanders hin geht, zwei gehen zu Stuttgart, kein Zombie zum HSV usw. Die werden auch in Kiel, also schon wieder, die Kugel den Berg wieder hochrollen müssen. Aber natürlich mit jedem Jahr 2. Liga, auch mit etwas besseren Möglichkeiten, mit Transfer-Erlösen usw. Ich bin echt mal gespannt, wie die das machen. Und Arminia Bielefeld, also Uwe Neuhaus, also hallo, vielleicht der neben Koshienad der erfolgreichste Trainerwechsel in dieser Saison. Bielefeld ist Rückrunden zweiter, glaube ich, hinter Paderborn, da habe ich das richtig im Kopf. Ich fand immer schon, dass Uwe Neuhaus ein komplett unterschätzter Trainer ist. Ich habe das auch oft gerne gesehen, wie seine Mannschaften versucht haben, Fußball zu spielen. In Bielefeld hat das jetzt sehr auf Vogelsammer und Kloss und lange Bälle und zügig nach vorne spielen abgesetzt und Fabian Kloss ist natürlich unfassbar.
24 Torbeteiligungen.
Ja, und wie alt ist er? Er ist irgendwie 31. Es haben ja auch schon die ersten versucht, ihn auszusortieren. Jeff Saebene hat das zumindest mal ein bisschen gepiesagt, damit er wieder etwas in die Gänge kommt. Das ist jenseits von Bielefeld Fabian Kloss und so weiter und in Bielefeld totale Legende, totaler Liebling, weil der auch so etwas altertümlich Mitreißendes hat. Da können die Bielefelder schon froh sein, dass sie den immer noch haben.
Mensch, da gerätst du ja richtig in Schwaben, Christoph.
Dabei ist es doch so, dass in Abwesenheit von anderen Gegnern sich Bochum und Bielefeld jetzt irgendwie so eine Art von Lokalderby erklärt haben. Wir in Bochum haben ja unsere richtigen Lokalderbys gegen Schalke und Dortmund schon lange nicht mehr. Die würden das da, glaube ich, in unserer Nachbarschaft auch nicht ernst nehmen. Aber die Abneigung zwischen Bielefeld und Bochum wird wechselseitig sehr, sehr ernst gemacht.
Dann wissen wir das jetzt noch mehr wertzuschätzen. Wir stellen fest, Uwe Neuhaus, Trainergott, Tim Halter sowieso Trainergott. Das sage ich als jemand, der ihn bei den Amateuren bei den Bayern auch schon häufiger gesehen hat. Genießt hier sehr, sehr hohe Wertschätzung und könnte, sollte er zum VfB wechseln, da auch wirklich einiges bewegen. Ganz interessant, du hast es einmal kurz angesprochen, dieser Umbruch, den Heustern mitgemacht hat, das vergisst man wieder viel zu leicht. Es gab in diesem Kader, der jetzt gespielt hat, gab es insgesamt nur drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben Spieler, die nicht vor der Saison von einem anderen Verein kamen. Alle anderen wurden geliehen, wurden gekauft. Da gab es einen unglaublichen Umbruch und es steht jetzt auch schon wieder in den Sternen, das hast du ja auch schon anmoderiert, dass das jetzt auch so weitergehen wird und dann dennoch eine solche Saison zu spielen, mit neuem Trainer, unfassbar. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen untergegangen.
Und ein neuer Manager, das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen.
Stimmt, genau.
Der ist ja, der ist ja, der Bäcker ist ja dann ein paar Kilometer die Autobahn runter nach zum HSV gewechselt. Also das ist schon, also da habe ich wirklich großen Respekt vor.
Den teilen wir zwei uns. Dann hatten wir noch die Partie zwischen Darmstadt und Aue, beide gerettet. Darmstadt 98 gewinnt diese Partie mit 1 zu 0, kommt so dann auf dem 10. Tabellenplatz raus. Erzgebirge Aue landet bei 40 Punkten auf dem Tabellenplatz 14 und konnte sich auch so vor dem Abstieg bewahren. Was sind das für zwei Mannschaften?
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, Darmstadt hat überhaupt nicht zu mir gesprochen. Also ich vermag das jetzt nicht. Ich vermag nichts Vernünftiges zu Darmstadt zu sagen. Was mir allerdings aufgefallen ist und auch gut gefallen hat, das Publikum dort ist sehr gut mitgegangen über die ganze Saison. Also obwohl das ja jetzt auch nicht so dolle war, 10. Platz und man hat natürlich da, die haben ja auch ihren Urlaub in der Bundesliga gemacht und sich da so ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, ein bisschen größer wieder gemacht. Jetzt bauen sie ihr Stadion auch noch um und also da hat man schon das Gefühl, dass die nach den Jahren der Krise und dieses kurzen Ausflugs in die Bundesliga, da steckt Potenzial drin und dieses Potenzial kommt durchaus auch vom Interesse und von der Leidenschaft des Publikums her. Also fußballerisch vermag ich da nicht viel zu sagen. Das war für mich so ein bisschen, aber das ist echt eine Fernbetrachtung, so eine ordentlich brave, aber auch irgendwie etwas konturlose Zweitligamannschaft.
Und hat dann Erzgebirge Aue da für dich mehr Konturen im Kontraft?
Erzgebirge Aue, für die habe ich ja eine Schwäche. Also wie jeder, der kein Herz aufs Stein hat. Ich meine, was die da hinkriegen, also das ist jetzt mal Standortnachteil hoch 23. Das ist ja nicht nur, weil Aue selber nur 17.500 Einwohner hat oder so was. Also da muss man erst mal jemand überzeugen, da hinzukommen. Also wenn man da in einer Gegend aufgewachsen ist, okay, aber stell dir vor, dich ruft jemand an und sagt, Mensch, willst du nicht nach Aue kommen? Aber du verdienst auch nicht so viel, wie anderswo. Also das ist nicht einfach. Und aus diesen Umständen machen die immer wahnsinnig viel. Und ich finde, dass sie auch sympathischerweise versucht haben, ordentlich Fußball zu spielen. Also was ich immer für ordentlich Fußball halte, also auch mal ein bisschen zu kombinieren und ein bisschen mal hinten rauszuspielen und nicht nur den langen Ball und den auf den zweiten und weiß der Teufel was. Von daher, wie gesagt, ist meine Sympathie für Aue ungetrübt, auch wenn natürlich Herr Leonhardt, der Vereinspräsidenten, eine etwas bizarre Figur ist. Diese wunderbare Rede. Was hat der Muttertag vor?
Muttertag zum Anlass genommen zu empfehlen, dass die Mütter die Erzgebirge DNA doch weiter tragen sollten oder die Frauen da draußen. Das ist ein Frauenbild. Das kommt dann auch von Untertage, dieses Frauenbild.
Genau, also das ist vielleicht jetzt nicht bei allem gesellschaftlichen Entwicklungen ganz weit vorne, aber das ist schon in Ordnung da. Und wenn man da hinfährt, das ist auch nett. Während ja zum Beispiel Dresden und Magdeburg so versuchen, so eine etwas, wie soll man sagen, einschüchternde Feindseligkeit zu signalisieren, es gibt einem auhe das Gefühl, dass sich alle freuen, dass man den Weg dahin gemacht hat. Und ich würde auch jedem nur sagen, der Anhänger eines Zweitligisten ist und den Weg gescheut hat, fahrt da mal hin. Das ist nett da.
Genau. Und der Nudeltopf, den es da gibt, soll legendär sein. So habe ich es zumindest schon in vielen anderen Podcasts gehört, ohne jemals selbst vor Ort gewesen zu sein. Wer ja in der nächsten Saison da auf jeden Fall auch nochmal die Reise hin antreten wird, sind zwei Mannschaften, die ebenfalls schon sehr, sehr lange in der 2. Liga mit dabei sind. Nämlich zum einen Kräuter Fürth seit der Saison 2013-2014. Und da haben wir einen Erstliga-Ausflug noch mit drin, der dann davor stattfand. Und den FC St. Pauli seit 2011 und 2012 in der 2. Fußball-Bundesliga. Die haben sich jetzt 2 zu 1 getrennt in einer Partie, die dann für beide keine Bedeutung mehr hatte. Fürth beschließt die Saison auf Tabellenplatz 13, St. Pauli auf Tabellenplatz 9. Und da haben wir die zweite Mannschaft, für die dieser Derby-Sieg des HSV irgendwie einen Knackpunkt in der Saison markiert hat. Oder überbewerte ich das da jetzt?
Also ich habe das Gefühl, die enttäuschten Fans, darüber haben wir ja eben im Zusammenhang mit dem MSV Duisburg geredet, weil das wirklich Freudlosigkeit im XXL-Format war. Aber bei St. Pauli habe ich den Eindruck, ist es nicht anders oder natürlich etwas anders. Da müssen wir ja jetzt mal die Relation sehen. Also bei aller Andersartigkeit des FC St. Pauli ist es natürlich ein topvermarkteter Verein und wahrscheinlich der, der von der Wirtschaftskraft auf Platz 3 oder 4 in der Liga steht. Das heißt, eigentlich hätte St. Pauli ein Aufstiegskandidat sein müssen. Davon waren sie aber dann doch am Schluss brutal weit entfernt und ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin da auch, was den FC St. Pauli betrifft, inzwischen ein bisschen ungnädig, weil die das jetzt über Jahre ihren großen wirtschaftlichen Vorteil nicht verstehen, in vernünftigen Fußball umzusetzen und gut, es wird vielleicht nächstes Jahr alles anders, aber da bin ich jetzt auch mal gespannt. Also irgendwie viel Geld, viel Stimmung und alles und über Jahre unheimlich wenig Fußball. Also das ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein Rätsel oder vielleicht auch kein Rätsel, weil halt in der DNA des Clubs vielleicht auch der Fußball nicht an allererster Stelle steht.
Ja und das ist, man hat zwar viele Tore erzielt, das liegt aber allein an der sehr guten Chancenverwertung. Nur Darmstadt 98 hat weniger häufig in Richtung des gegnerischen Tores geschossen, also der FC St. Pauli liegt da auf Tabellenplatz 17 in dieser Torschuss-Tabelle, in einer Gesellschaft mit Aue, Magdeburg, Sandhausen und eben Darmstadt noch dahinter, wo man sagt, da gehört der FC St. Pauli nicht hin. Das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, vermutlich gewesen, warum man mit Markus Kauczynski dann nicht jetzt auch in die nächste Saison gehen wollte, sondern da jetzt gewechselt hat zu Jules Luhukai. Da bin ich mir aber ehrlich gesagt, nachdem, was ich da sehen konnte, das waren allerdings wenig Spiele über 90 Minuten, um ehrlich zu sein, bin ich mir auch nicht so ganz sicher, ob das dann der Trainer sein kann, der da offensiv den Bock umstößt, um jetzt mal Thomas Deutz zu zitieren, was man immer machen sollte.
Naja, also wer Jules Luhukai verpflichtet, der weiß, dass es seinen Fans keinen Rosengarten anlegen wird. Also das ist auch klar. Er hat natürlich, Luhukai hat eine ganz ausgezeichnete Bilanz als Aufstiegsexperte. Ihm ist das ja, ich weiß gar nicht wie oft, Augsburg, Hertha BSC und weiß der Teufel, wo noch, ist das gelungen. Aber da muss man sehr, sehr viel Geduld mitbringen, wenn man ins Stadion gehen will, weil das ist halt äußerst zweckmäßiger Fußball. Und das ist jetzt die höfliche Formulierung.
Ja, ist die Frage, ob das dann wirklich so gut zur DNA von St. Pauli passt. Aber das ist nicht unser Problem. Unser Problem ist nur noch, dass wir mit Kräuter-Fürth die letzte Mannschaft einordnen müssen, über die wir noch nicht gesprochen haben. Was war das für eine Saison für die Fedder?
Keine gute. Also die waren schon zwischendurch auf auf dünnem Eis unterwegs. Also das hat sich ja auch dann ausgedrückt in einem Trainerwechsel. Also ein bisschen ist es vielleicht so eigentlich ein Club, der es schon immer wieder verstanden hat, auch gute Transfers und geschickte Transfers und sowas zu machen, aber damit jetzt in dieser Saison so mittel dabei gelegen hat und auch so fußballerisch so mittel eine Identität entwickelt hat. Und ich glaube, die sind auch in Fürth jetzt sehr froh, dass die Saison vorbei ist, man sich so ein bisschen schütteln kann und dann das ganze nächste Saison vielleicht mit ein bisschen mehr Werf und frischen Ideen anzugehen.
Die frischen Ideen könnten von Stefan Leitel kommen, der eben dann ab Februar auf der Trainerbank saß. Jetzt hat er dann zum ersten Mal auch eine Vorbereitung zur neuen Saison, darf bei den Transfers mitsprechen. Mal gucken, ob sich dann ein bisschen was verändert bei Fürth. Und wie wir sie dann in der nächsten Saison erleben, wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft, Christoph, wir haben alle Mannschaften mal wenigstens kurz einsortiert und damit ein wunderschönes Schleifchen gebunden um diese Zweitligasaison. Ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast und deine Expertise so gut zur Schaustellen konntest. Es gibt, glaube ich, wenige Leute, die sich in der 2. Liga so gut auskennen. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst, Christoph. Ihr könnt Christoph Biermann folgen auf Twitter, ad.chbiermann und natürlich solltet ihr seine Bücher lesen. Wer das nicht getan hat, der hat den Fußballjournalismus nie geliebt. Ich danke euch sehr für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es wird in dieser Woche hoffentlich noch einen weiteren Kurzpass geben und außerdem ist in der Nacht auf Montag die Schlusskonferenz zum 34. Spieltag der 1. Liga erschienen. Ich wünsche euch eine gute Zeit, bis bald, macht's gut, ciao!